congratulations on this what does this
mean this is such a big night you have
the biggest honor and this is a very
special event every year what does it
mean to you to sort of bring awareness
well is such an honor and I'm so
grateful to receive that amazing check
for my kids our Wellness Center to
Melbourne Australia that it will help so
many people with the programs that
support them going through the cancer
journey so it means that is wonderful
the lifetime achievement award was a big
honor also and that wonderful dance
number they did with all my songs I
didn't expect that so that was that was
wonderful made me smile and how are you
feeling you look vibrant and fabulous
right
what has this year been like and how are
you feeling and you know there's so much
talk about you and how you are and
everyone's worried about you do feel the
support and love I do I just want
everyone to know that I'm here I'm doing
great what happens is the headlines kind
of cope go crazy and then we think oh my
god we can't believe she's coming
they're gonna wheel her out but you see
him vibrant and I'm doing really well
I'm really healthy it was a challenging
year because I broke my sacrum and I had
to learn to walk again and these things
but I'm strong and I'm back and I'm
feeling good
such a star and so famous and you going
through a battle with cancer publicly
inspires so many other people do you
realise that you can sort of brighten
people's day or make them keep going by
being just you I hear that and I'm very
touched by that and it's a
responsibility that I try to you know I
don't try I am positive about my life
and about my journey and I hope that can
touch other people to be positive about
this tell me what the check is doing
exactly and for people that haven't
heard about your Cancer Center what goes
on there and what will this money
provide further people but we have
research and wellness that is not
provided by the government the
government pay for all the other things
so we have to lend for pies or the other
things so some will be going to the
wellness programs that will be
yoga and group therapies and music
therapy and acupuncture and these things
and then the other half would be going
to research so that's how we do it and
it's it's wonderful it's wonderful to
have a passion when you see someone like
Jane presenting to you and these dancers
performing sort of a medley of of your
moments and your songs what does that
mean tune is there's one particular
moment or one song that sticks out to
you like well that's my favorite child
that I've ever put in the world they're
all they're always like I only have one
child so she is my favorite but I hate
it when you have a lot you love them all
equally in slightly different ways so
that's how I feel people think of you do
you want them to think of you for sandy
and grease or do you want them to think
of you for what you've put forward for
other people and humanity and that's
laughter be work you've done I think
people are going to take from that what
they I wanted what they choose to take
from it I'm happy if I'm entertaining
people
then I'm happiest when I'm helping
people so it's a way that goes a perfect
day for you last question how do you
spend a perfect day today I got up early
I fed my dog and cat at a cup of tea
they've brought one - my husband had a
really nice morning I mean today was a
busy day but just to be at home with my
animals my husband maybe have Chloe
there visiting just hanging out which is
something I've really never done I have
a little miniature horses that I play
with and we have chickens and I'm a
country girl did you ever get the
million dollars for the sandy pans
the last time we saw oh that's in
November there's the julienne auction on
November 2nd I believe it is my $15 and
I'm ready to partner up with whoever as
900,000 whatever and we're gonna get
those sandy pans honor we're so happy
for you
you